[Applaudissements]
elle va bien elle vit bien beaucoup
d'ambition on a une équipe compétitive
tous les athlètes sélectionnés sont
montés sur des internationaux au cours
de cette année 2022 voilà donc on est
capable avec nos athlètes de jouer les
premiers rôles et il y a beaucoup
d'envies et forcément quand on est
athlète et compétiteur en équipe de
France on prend le départ pour la gagne
[Musique]
les objectifs je me les suis fixé avec
les staffs pas que de mon côté avec avec
les entraîneurs mais le bilan
quantitatif et qualitatif on le fera à
l'issue de ce championnat du monde
[Musique]
une bonne préparation je dirais qu'une
plutôt qu'une répétition oui certains
vont découvrir un championnat du monde à
domicile avec beaucoup de concurrence
forcément une intensité beaucoup
d'engagements dans les compétitions avec
les adversaires Olivier que les
adversaires viennent ici aussi à
Saint-Quentin dans la perspective des
Jeux de prendre de l'information donc
les cours seront très engagés très dense
et oui c'est une bonne préparation pour
monter en puissance à moins de deux ans
des jeux
[Applaudissements]